Do you recommend the use of the low-submide while using iver-vected and fed-bendazole?
I don't know exactly what you're asking there.
So, the close-amide is...
I don't look that up.
Oh, that's another tapeworm drug.
Okay, so now I know what the question is.
So, there is a thought process out there that the reason why iver-vected and fed-bendazole and or fed-bendazole work is because...
for cancer is that because cancer is parasite, of course, that's why it works.
So, you take an antiparasitic medication and it's going to kill the cancer.
I totally disagree with that line of thinking.
I don't think that's why iver-vected and fed-bendazole work.
The close-amide is another drug that works on tapeworms where iver-vected and fed-bendazole do not work on tapeworms.
They work on roundworms and somewhat on liver flukes.
But the close-amide is going to work on tapeworms.
So, that's the theory as well to the close-amide also because then we're going to hit all the parasites.
We totally don't agree with that.
And the reason is that studies on iver-vected and fed-bendazole and why it tends to work with cancer...
There's multiple things, but it's not because of its antiparasitic properties.
The main reason why I believe that those work with cancer is they up-regulate the P53 genetic pathway.
So, remember your genetics. The P53 pathway is a tumor suppressor pathway.
So, remember you have all these different tumor suppressor genes that turn on if you have a cell that goes in rapid replication.
So, you've heard of the BRCA genes. All the BRCA genes are tumor suppressor genes, particularly in the breast and the ovaries.
People with BRCA gene defects.
If a cell goes into rapid replication, the defects prevent the BRCA tumor suppressor system from destroying that cell.
And then the cell can continue to replicate thereby finally giving you a diagnosis of cancer.
Now, there are other tumor suppressor genes. The P53 is actually the most prominent tumor suppressor gene.
If one has defects in their P53 system, they're going to have a more difficult time destroying cancer for the inside out, what's called the intrinsic apoptotic pathway.
So, the intrinsic inside the cell apoptotic death cell death pathway is going to be less apt to kill a growing cancer if a person has defects other P53 genes.
That's why we test for those.
However, if we up-regulate the P53 system, whether you have defects or not, you're going to have a better chance of that turning on and destroying the cancer.
So, there's lots of things that up-regulate the P53.
Tumoric up-regulates the P53 system.
Green T extract, EGCG, can up-regulate the P53 system.
Ivermectin and fed mendisol also up-regulate the P53 pathway.
So, remember, if we can up-regulate tumor suppressor pathways, meaning increase the function of them, then if we can increase the function of them, they have a better chance of destroying the cancer from the inside out,
via the intrinsic apoptotic pathway.
So, I do not believe that it's the anti-paracidic properties of Ivermectin and fed mendisol that destroy cancer.
It's the genetic effect of the genetic P53 pathway that doesn't.
Now, there's other studies that show other pathways, metabolic pathways, that these also work on helping destroy cancer.
But there's not really data to say that it has anything to do with parasites.